this man has got his quarterback summit
he's got a whole bunch of folks in the
National Football League that he has
mentored and tutor he spent seven
seasons in the National Football League
he is Carson Carson Palmer's brother
Jordan Palmer good to see you sir
heavens I know Jesse Palmer happens stop
Rodgers happens when people don't really
know and get Arnold Palmer's you get
that I wish I was actually I just I
think I have water in my face I just had
a Ron Burgundy moment okay I look down
at my card and it says for some reason
your younger brother of Carson Palmer on
bond or many of your accolades and I
just read the one says read the name I'm
Rich Eisen brother of Jeff Eisen brother
yeah I don't have no message for San
Diego thankfully okay let's get let's
get into this I saw Kyle Allen you it's
funny I looked down at my phone when I'm
in London and I'm in the meeting with
all the guys getting ready for the game
and it's a video from you you texted me
this video that I guess you put together
mashed-up of not only his slightly sent
me from a clip that I had when I was
sitting you're sitting here for the
chair talking about Kyle Allen when you
were here a couple years ago prior to
the draft and what he's done for
Carolina has been amazing I'm calling
the game and I thought he was sitting in
a rocking chair not making his fifth
career start Jordan I mean what do you
what do you think of what he's been able
to do is this a surprise to you in any
way shape well I mean the level of
success the some of the things the first
five and OH undrafted got like some of
the notable stats remember surprised
it's cool it's exciting I'm not
surprised that he when he got his
opportunity he was gonna play well and I
mean I said that three years ago sitting
in this chair that he's gonna be a guy
who plays in this league when he gets an
opportunity the poise that you don't
have to know a lot about the position or
the sport to look at a guy who's super
poised and a guy who looks rattled and
from day one he's just poised he's been
through a lot of success he's been
through a lot of adversity which is the
first thing I think quarterbacks have to
be able to deal with and then they have
to be able to the moment can't be too
big for them and it's not so much about
arm talent and height and what school
you went to those are those are elements
but they're not foundational elements
and poise and confidence in dealing with
adversity and success those are
foundational elements he
have that I didn't I don't know more
than anybody else I just had visibility
earlier and more consistently in his
career to be able to say I'm not
surprised long in the meeting where that
video were you texted me that video you
know I'm like when was the last time he
threw an interception and lost mm-hmm
any game and it was the same time was
when he was his last year in at the
University of Houston against cliff
Kingsbury's Texas Tech team a couple of
November's ago that was the last time
either of those things happened how long
can this go on do you think in Caroline
well I think when you have a quarterback
in because I was a backup you you go
through that that part of your career
and so you kind of know the situation
you're hoping for and so I think this is
pretty consistent with most backup
quarterbacks situation you're hoping for
is when you get a chance to go in the
three elements you really want is a good
run game a good play caller and a good
defense having a great individual
receiver isn't necessarily really
valuable because you didn't get any reps
with him I backed up my brother and we
had Chad and tio I wasn't necessarily
excited to go in the game I had never
really thrown with those guys and it
takes a lot of time and but if you have
a great run game a great defense and a
great play caller that's really what the
situation you looking for I look at
Gardner Minshew I think he has those
three things look at Kyle Allen I think
he has those three things and so with
Kyle I think this can go because the
running back can continue to go north
Turner ain't going anywhere and the
defense can continue to go and Kyle
outside of a couple sack fumbles didn't
in turn it over yes he's been amazing
honestly I'm sitting there and he threw
one ball in third quarter on the
sideline where Kurt was like whoa he
just like where he thought it was a
little bit risky other than that there
was it was just easy and and I we spoke
to Todd Bowles before the game the
defensive coordinator for Tampa said it
was more difficult to prepare for Kyle
Allen and the offense than it was in
week two when cam was potentially banged
up so the question I have is I asked Ron
Rivera what happens when the doctor says
Cam's 100% healthy and cam comes to him
and says the same thing and he said
we'll see and then
now he doesn't deal in hypotheticals
yeah how do you think this plays out for
Kyle Allen you know I think what they're
sitting on right now is if you look at
that quarterback room they just drafted
will Grier who I think is gonna be a
really good pro in the third round
they've got Kyle who's making league
minimum as little as the smallest amount
of money you can possibly pay somebody
and still have them play and then you've
got cam who's done all of these things
where he's been MVP he's been all these
things at the end of the year the goal I
would say is to have a great year
playoff run and have will Grier as
developmental one guy who's your
quarterback moving forward and somebody
that you can trade or create value for
whether that's cam comes back plays at a
high level he's your guy and you can
trade Kyle or Kyle continues to roll and
you've got options with Cam at the end
of the year that would be the goal now
you can also they can go other the other
way Kyle can start to play poorly Cam
could come back and not play well and
then you got to go back to Kyle so
there's just so many complexities with
it
but this is a team that's winning and I
feel like this locker rooms really
rallied around Kyle and it's it's it's a
difficult complex situation but there
are multiple good outcomes here I just
know this this NFL I would say most gyms
are looking to this the model the
desired model is cheap quarterback who
can win us games Sam straight cap space
and build around it while we have this
window so we can't get in too much in
the nuances of last game in this game
big picture here they still have some
interesting ingredients well I mean
maybe the best option could be is if cam
just gets surgery or gets something
going on with his foot and they could
figure out what he is again as a healthy
guy if he is a healthy shoe
the shoulder is not a concern anymore is
it well I don't know I I had said it in
the off season you know what he did is
he had reconstruction of shoulder
surgery however you want to phrase that
I don't know much about his surgery he
had a big shoulder surgery on his
throwing arm and then he had to rehab it
and then he spent a lot of time with Tom
House who is the best in the business in
terms of retraining the throwing motion
building up the muscle so we tried to
tweak such as some extent his throwing
motion I just think that's a lot to do
in a really short offseason the surgery
itself is big three
ham itself is big so I don't know where
he's out I'm not sitting there watching
them throw but I know this the foot is a
period of time that thing those things
heal those are common the shoulder when
he gets back and psychologically feels
like it's when he gets back I mean Cam
Newton's Cam Newton right I'm just guys
dominated at the NFL this isn't some guy
who's in my opinion done by any means
it's just what is what's the best move
for the Panthers and it's a new
ownership it's a you know a lot of new
people there and and they got a really
good thing gonna now Jordan Palmer here
on the Rich Eisen show is this the Sam
Donald the one that we saw this past
week was the the AFC Offensive Player of
the Week is this is this the kid I mean
it's crazy to see you change one player
out how different that I mean right it
was crazy yeah I I the thing I'm so
impressed with Sam with is this was a
long month this isn't just a regular
injury this is a kind of a
self-inflicted like bummer injury and he
got a lot of flack for it and he's 22
and the new coaches are historically you
know underperforming as an offense and
there's just a lot that he took on I
think in this month of being quarantined
and being away from everything
mentally that's that's a challenging
thing for him to be able to do that and
then just lock in and do what he did the
other day the cowboys man and and then
here come the Cowboys that that you know
it's their owner's birthday they're in
New York they've got Romo and Nance I
mean it's the whole country's watching
and man they need to win and the Jets I
mean Donald was terrific but is that is
that is that jet fans are hoping to be
is that the guy is this gonna be him
yeah so his ability to block everything
out and just isolate this game this game
plan execute he showed this a bunch in
his career he did this he did he did the
whole one game season at SC that year
when he rolled his freshman year he has
a history of this his first game as a
rookie he throws a pick six then traffic
leads the Drive like his ability to come
in was prior to last week his best game
as a problem totally so that's the
question when I'm wondering is like you
know Jets fans can't get one great game
from Sam Donald per year I know this is
it and and and this week is the perfect
example of it it's Monday night football
comes Brady
Bella check into their house these are
the games that they need to win
absolutely and it's time to start doing
that that's why I'm wondering who he is
yeah I think I think he's a guy who can
play what he did this last weekend at a
consistent level continuing to put
pieces around him I think they've taken
strides as an offensive line obviously
lavey on with Sam is different than lay
beyond without Sam he was gonna be
there's just more options there's more
things you can do with them right and
the he missed out on some timing I think
this they continue to build on what
happened on Sunday versus the Cowboys
that's a good Cowboys team to look it's
a hard game to win yeah you know I would
agree with you and yeah Sam's back and
everyone's excited but it's different
than bringing back some twelve-year it's
different than when breeze comes back
and you literally know exactly what
you're getting yeah this is the second
year and so for him to come back and
those guys to rally and play confident
and play good on D and run around and
fly around and make plays that was
exciting to see and I think Sam's able
to build on this well and then of course
you know from the or jordan jordan
palmer here on the rich guys that show
guys that uh you have mentored and
worked with i mean josh allen is a guy
that we should be talking about to hear
he's form1 the bills are quite a
surprise so far how much what what does
he need to work on right now I think the
thing that this offseason really is
dedicated to it was just developing more
touch and anticipation not in him
learning how to throw with touch he has
a really strong arm so and people
usually when a guy has a big strong arm
they think that they just throw the ball
hard all the time josh has the ability
to do everything but because he has a
strong arm traditionally over his career
he's waited and being able to drive it
in there and fit it into Windows that no
one else can and so he's really
developed and Cole Beasley is helpful in
that regard and and John Brown the
addition and receiver is helpful in that
regard so he's gotten a lot better as
the seasons gone on with touch and
anticipation but for him it's continuing
to get better at situational football
it's no surprise they have a really good
defense and they're running the ball and
they're really efficient in the red zone
I think on their 14 trips they've scored
10 touchdowns mm-hmm so it's getting
better at protecting the football
managing the game when you have a
defense like that and you have a high
completion percentage it's really
managing the game and playing really
good situational football
that's the biggest opportunity because
they have I like a lot about the bills
I like their play color I like I like
they're deep they're just a lot to like
they're and they're in pole position
right now being I think foreign ones
they are they I mean there's their their
stand as much as they can on the
Patriots tail and and right now they're
leading the pack in terms of a wild-card
spot of Jordan Palmer here on the Rich
Eisen show is Josh Rosen a cautionary
tale a sad tale what type of tale is
what's going on with Josh Rosen it's a
bummer because I know he can play he's
got all the physical tools mentally he's
off the charts intelligent you just look
at and this is a bummer I've looked at
this is now two different isolated
situations different teams that I just
don't think are situations where you can
have find success Arizona last year
combination of that it's not an
indictment on Arizona it was the
situation it was the personnel was
injuries it was a new staff really
difficult situation fired the offensive
coordinator in the McCoy early on and
then he goes to Miami and all the the
chaos that's kind of ensuing there and
he's just been in two kind of situations
where I don't see how you succeed and I
feel for the guy I will say this though
this is a right place right time league
wrong place wrong time league whether
it's you making the cut Kyle Allen or a
superstar getting drafted by the wrong
team and it would his career would have
gone different yeah either way so it's
right place right time and he's been in
the wrong place the wrong time twice I
think it's a matter of time if he gets
in the right place at the right time I
think he's a guy so who what's the right
place for him I mean give me give me a
right place scenario at this point
anywhere anything is up you know I I
don't know about I don't know about a
team or to say this team that you know I
mean a scheme of somebody that's out
there did he complain a lot of different
teams I don't think he has to play in
some specific scheme do you think he's
gonna get a shot he's got to get a shot
as a backup and then get in I mean is
that the way it's gonna depend on what
Miami does right cuz if they're gonna
take somebody at 1 or 2 this year we all
know what they're gonna do they may we
all know what they want to do we all
know who
they want you know there's no there's no
secret
I heard is gonna screw it up I mean it's
entirely possible that he's gonna win
two games and then all of a sudden
they're not gonna have to it because
that's I heard that Jordan I mean you're
in you're in this business you know
people I heard that at the draft in
Dallas yeah two drafts ago yeah I heard
the Dolphins are so in love with two and
they're gonna make sure they get him
yeah I heard that too drafts ago
so we all know I mean it Miami he'll
either be a back let me in and I assume
they're not gonna want somebody in their
third year in the quarterback room
backing up to or they're gonna want to
bring in somebody yeah gone about that
differently I mean the Redskins went
with two got rookies from the same draft
class and Kirk Cousins and RG three so
there's there's there's different ways
to do it
I think Ryan Fitzpatrick is one of the
best guys to have on your team if you're
developing a young player sure but I
think Josh Rosen could be great at that
as well and and so it just depends on
what Miami does and if he gets out of
there and I would love to see him get
become an unrestricted free agent Josh
Rosen and get a chance to go somewhere
and compete and choose his own destiny
because the biggest difference between
college and pro is in college these kids
pick where they want to go the pros he
was drafted Arizona and he was traded to
Miami right at 0 saying either of those
I'd love to see Rosen get a chance to
choose his path the only issue of being
a young quarterback with Ryan
Fitzpatrick in the room isn't because of
who Ryan is or what he wants or he's or
how open he is to mentor it's just that
he's got this this aura mmm that for
some reason he will always wind up
getting in the game yeah as the starter
I've never seen its own king he's were
almost difficult guys to ever compete
against because he's so likable he's
everybody loves him he's hysterical he's
smart he's witty and he always gets a
start yeah he started over you right
yeah he started his Carson hurt his
elbow and Ryan went in his first year
ago I mean how many stories have someone
so hurt them and then Ryan Edwards was
five and Oh in Buffalo yeah yeah um
what's going on with Haskins do you
think there's no not is he not ready is
he really not ready will that be
possible
I I think to some extent none of these
guys are ready
because they're playing doesn't
necessarily mean they're ready there's a
ton of that ever all these rookies need
to develop they may need more reps they
may need to understand the verbage
better they may need to just play more
doings ago he didn't play a lot and call
it no I know you only started here you
don't need it Donald needed it Sanchez
more years though I mean it really only
played one year now sure Biscay is a guy
who I'd say also only played one year
that's right
but between two I just think it's a
difficult situation right now and that
one's hard to pick down with the way
that that organizations ran and run a J
and now he's out and I will say this
Kevin O'Connell I think is one of the
next great young LK coaches that's gonna
get to become a big former on the game
order back right no Kevin was at San
Diego State okay he was drafted by the
Patriots okay did draft training good
friend of mine and but he's been
promoted Oh seed so he's he's so they
have a good play caller they got a good
quarterback room I just think that
there's a lot of a lot uncertainty
around huddling got their last one for
you Jordan Palmer next next level at for
me you're also calling games college
games for Fox Sports as well what does
it look like that we all know to was
there and Herbert who else is in the
quarterback class that's coming up
burrow is a guy who caught my attention
last year because the first half of the
season statistically it wasn't super
exciting and then something changed the
second half of the season and so I got a
chance to watch a little tape of both
and spend some time with him this
offseason and you like him huh yeah you
start talking to this kid you realize
this is the upper echelon of confidence
of kids and I think confidence is the
most important trait in a quarterback so
it's right away where my eye goes this
kids in terms of the guys that I've been
around whatever capacity he's up there
in good confidence I'm not talking about
the bad kind and then you go man he's
got a lot of players around him and then
you look at I think it's Joe Murphy from
the Saints who's coming over his past
game coordinator they're running a lot
of NFL stuff he's getting a chance to
play good teams and he continues to play
well against good teams he had a monster
Texas game this game he went off it's
got Bama and November 9th he's got an
awesome test in front of him if he
continues at this pace he's gonna have
the SEC championship if he you know he's
gonna be able to have a resin
that you know - is maybe the only person
that's comfortable - who else anybody
else like her I really like Jordan love
out of Utah state really really talented
guy can make all the throws see uh
Steven Montez at Colorado has a little
Josh Allen in him really
shifty athlete big kid huge arm this is
gonna be a more top-heavy class I think
Juke froms a guy that a lot of people
talk about I think now that now I can
say this this makes sense Jake from
keeping Justin fields on the bench at
Georgia sure I mean Wow right is as
impressive as any throw that Jake
Fromm's made and fields us from Atlanta
and a lot of people wanted feels a start
and it's not that fields wasn't ready to
dominate obviously obviously right yeah
but they just couldn't take Jake off the
field and that's as impressive as
something I've seen in a while but
nobody's pound at the table for - not
only being number one but being so
special in terms of a unicorn and our
buddy Dilfer do you agree yeah I agree
yeah there's something - it has an aura
and a way around him when when he's in
the room everybody thinks that they're
gonna win they think that they can win
the whole thing with tua he is a dill
first term he says there's thermostat or
thermometer leaders thermometer tells
you what the temperature is in the room
a thermit at a thermostat dictates the
temperature in the room he's a
thermostat leader it sounds like
something I would say yeah but yeah I
mean - is ready to rock he the only time
I've ever used this word is with to her
he's an explosive thrower
Josh Allen has a really strong arm I
wouldn't use the word explosive
something about - it it's explosive but
he also can control it and put it where
he wants all right and then yeah like
that you just got my here - before I let
you go are you concerned about Baker I'm
just concerned about the whole situation
like what why you've got a lot of people
in that team coaches and players who
just haven't won a bunch of NFL games
don't have a bunch of Super Bowl winners
and playoff guys starting with Freddie
kitchens it's been around a lot and and
it's an awesome guy and I think a really
smart offensive mind but hadn't not
hadn't been and this is for some in that
situation and then you've got obj and
all these really big personalities but
it's not a bunch of guys who've won at
other places and they're bringing that
winning mentality in and so now that
things are getting difficult it's hard
if you don't have that not just the
vocal leader but the experienced guy in
the locker room and I mean I was with
the Bengals when it was Chad teo pac-man
tank Johnson Chris Henry Cedric Benson
rest in peace like a lot of big
personalities but she had a Carson
Palmer you had a Marvin Lewis people who
had been there and could and can Corral
those things that's I think the the void
there and and so I just don't know how
long all that the the talent and stuff
takes you and that division is you know
it's up in the air but there's still
some some good teams in it good to see a
man let's get you back on as soon as
possible as much as you'd like Jordan
Palmer at JW palms on Twitter at Jordan
Palmer on Instagram for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app